hey Ron I'm Abby char welcome to Abby's
kitchen and I'm back with another what a
in a date youtuber review I get so many
requests when it comes to different
youtubers videos to review and one that
has come up quite a lot if a natural
vegan now I have watched a bunch of her
videos over the past month or so and it
felt like a breath of fresh air amidst
all of the Frehley drama and PS if
you're not already subscribed you
definitely are gonna want to do that
right now
because I have some serious crazy
controversial Frehley information coming
up on the channel soon so one of the
things that I love about unnatural vegan
is that she doesn't claim to be a
nutrition professional or a registered
dietitian she actually says that in her
videos and she points people towards
some really great nutrition information
and resources in the description for her
videos so this is how you serve your
audience really well and I personally
really appreciate it so without further
ado let's take a look at her diet all of
this stuff
and banana so I love a good oatmeal bowl
in the morning and this is a super
healthy way to start the day some really
great energizing carbs with fiber we've
got some fruit in there we've got some
healthy fats from the the peanut butter
and the almonds and the chia seeds and
the coconut I love this she also gives a
lot of great little kind of fast meal
hacks and prep tips so I really
appreciate that nice little breakfast
there let's check out the macros on the
oatmeal 26 grams of fat 70 2.5 grams of
carbs and 16.3 grams of protein some
roasted chickpeas very delicious super
crisp so good some tomato some of this
smart bacon two slices of that that's
really yummy and a little bit of drift
dressing the garlic dressing which is
really so simple salad salads great I
love that there's lots of vegetables in
there she's got some protein from chick
peas and lentils there's probably some
protein in that kind of like soy based
bacon or fakin or whatever and some fats
from the dressing and I left that she's
keeping it really simple I mean I find a
lot of youtubers and bloggers like show
these really elaborate meals for every
meal of the day and the reality is most
of us don't really eat that way all the
time because it would take up our entire
day just prepping our meals for
Instagram so I like that she's just
throwing together a really simple salad
probably with all the things that she's
got in the fridge so I love that
let's look at the macros on her lunch
fourteen point three grams of fat
thirty-six grams of carbs and fourteen
point seven grams of protein so plain
plain soy yogurt with a little bit of
trail mix just one of the trail mixes
that they sell at the store and just a
tiny bit of maple syrup mixed in with so
again I love that easy peasy
snack we've got that hunger crushing
combination of fiber protein and fats in
there she's got dried fruit she's got
nuts she's got yogurt and while most
kind of vegan based yogurts I find don't
have very much protein compared to
normal dairy yogurt especially like a
Greek yogurt this one our she's got like
11 grams per cup so it's pretty good
let's look at the macros on her snack
17.5 grams of fat 26.2 grams of carbs
and 15 point 5 grams of protein
thing that I had in my last for a day
but this one is carrot and broccoli and
potato and chickpeas and the main
difference I guess is that I roasted the
chickpeas separately that makes them
super super crunchy and delicious I
didn't cook them first just soak them
for several hours so that sounds delish
I am obsessed with crispy chickpeas so I
concur with her they are delicious
and that looks like a really
well-balanced vegan meal I mean she's
got lots of different vegetables in
there she's got some whole grains she's
got some fat from the vinaigrette she's
got her protein from the crispy
chickpeas basically everything you want
in one ball and I'm like really digging
her style in general when it comes to
meal preparation it's all seems like
really easy and simple and doable and
accessible not overly expensive there's
not any crazy ingredients that you have
to go like searching all over the city
for so this seems like something that
even like a single person who just wants
to eat really well could easily pull off
on a weeknight let's check out the
macros on dinner 11 grams of fat 3 grams
of carbs and 16 grams of protein
or just like an olive oil vinaigrette
just there's so many options I bring
that up because I think it's easy I mean
I know that I do this where you kind of
get caught up thinking that you have to
tweak all these different recipes and
find these different recipes that you
want but sometimes it's just as simple
as taking something that you like just
like a bare-bones healthy like green
bean great kind of bowl and just
different I love that I love that she's
making it so easy for people to kind of
make it their own
she's kind of giving like a formula as
in like have your whole grains have your
vegetables have your beam or legume or
your your your plant-based protein in
there which is ultimately what us as
registered dieticians do promote you to
do like we want to talk about the plate
method where like half of your plate
should be veggies a quarter your whole
grains a quarter your protein so I love
this I love that she's just giving
recommendations in terms of like switch
up the green switch up the veggie switch
up the dressing and you got a new dress
doesn't need to be so complicated you
don't need to kind of dream up these
elaborate recipes and menus every single
night of the week so I can totally see
why she has such an amazing following
pineapple pretty good price 177 each
that's not bad for a good size you know
sometimes they're a dollar but then
they're like tiny little pineapple so
it's like okay this so I love pineapple
I put it in my breakfast I put in my
smoothies I had it in my oatmeal it's
such a great fruit so I love that she's
finishing her day off with a fruit very
very healthy of course but if she wanted
to bulk that up and add some kind of
protein or fat whether it's with yogurt
that would also be a really great way to
just make it a little bit more satiating
but I've been so lucky with clementines
and pineapple lately so that's nice and
that is it thank you so much everybody I
hope you enjoyed it so this is key right
here I love that she puts on the screen
that she's taking supplements her
multivitamin her vitamin D her choline I
mean this is stuff that a lot of vegan
youtubers don't talk about they don't
they don't talk about it or maybe
they're not even taking it and I think
that's a real Miss Justice because a lot
of the followers out there who are
seeing this and seeing their diet and
they're not thinking that maybe they
need to add a supplement into their diet
to fill some of those nutritional gaps
so I love that she is kind of talking a
little bit about her supplement regime
as well okay so here is what I love
about this channel first of all it is so
easy and accessible I find that a lot of
vegan youtubers out there create these
recipes or these kind of these menus
that are so elaborate and there's so
many ingredients and like huge
quantities of ingredients that you would
feel like overwhelmed trying to get
started just eating a little bit more
plant-based all of her recipes seem
simple easy affordable accessible you
don't have to go to a specialty grocery
stores just to find any of these
ingredients all of these would be at
your local farmers market or your local
grocery store so thank you thank you
thank you a natural vegan for making it
seem like we can all get on board with
this plant-based thing number two I feel
like she is a very intuitive normal
eater and that is rare on the internet
these days I feel like when I watch her
you know she's the first to admit that
Sunday's are not necessarily always
gonna be perfect healthy eating days and
that is totally okay that's what normal
healthy balanced intuitive mindful
eating is all about like I always say
it's all about just listening to your
body and trusting that it knows exactly
what you need and I think that she does
a really good job at communicating that
and number three no [ __ ] claims this
woman is not claiming that eating her
way is going to lead to weight loss
clear your skin cure
cancer boosts your metabolism etc now
I've watched a bunch of videos and she
doesn't push any kind of expensive vegan
products or juice cleanses or any kind
of crazy stuff like that she's also the
first to suggest that you know you seek
out resources like health care providers
and registered dietitians and things
like that so this is a must when it
comes to the vegan Picchu space because
she's not claiming she is necessarily an
expert
she's just sharing her own unique vegan
journey and I think that's awesome
[Music]
so let's tally up the totals for the day
she's getting 70 1.9 grams of fat two
hundred forty six point five grams of
carbs and sixty two point five grams of
protein that amounts to about thirty
four percent from fat 53% from carbs and
thirteen percent from proteins so taking
into consideration for calories and her
macronutrient distribution I would say
she's got a really well-balanced diet
and in conjunction of course with her
multivitamin she's gonna get all the
nutrients she needs for a healthy vegan
diet so guys I hope you enjoyed this
episode of my what I eat in a day
youtuber review of unnatural vegan if
you did be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below some youtubers
who you'd like me to review subscribe to
the channel and I'll see you next time
on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]